[موسيقى]
النشيد الرسمي الاوكراني يصلح من جديد في
سماء خرسا بعد اكثر من ثمانيه اشهر من
السيطره الروسيه والسكان يطول صفحه مليئه
بالكوابيس
خائفين كان الخروج من المنزل مخيفا الجنود
الروسو كانوا في كل مكان لقد اختفى الكثير
من الناس وحدثت الكثير من عمليات الاختطاف
كنا ننتظر جنودنا مثل الالهه نحن سعداء
للغايه
الحرب
يوم الاثنين الاحتفال مع السكان باستعاده
سيطره الاوكرانيه على مدينه خرسانه
كيف حالكم
شكرا
هو المكان الوحيد الذي يتسنى فيه للسكان
شحن هواتفهم عبر مولدات الطاقه واستخدام
الانترنت عبر الجهاز الاتصال بالاقمار
الاصطناعيه والقوات الروسيه قامت بتدمير
البنيه التحتيه الى حد كبير خلال المعارك
ليس هناك كهرباء ولا ماء ولا اتصالات
هاتفيه الاشخاص الذين ليست لديهم سوده في
الكهربائيه منازلهم بارده جدا
لترتيب الاوضاع خاصه مع اقتراب فصل الشتاء
الكهربائيه خرسانه
[تصفيق]
تاريخ مصعوبه الظروف المعيشيه الراهنه الا
ان ذلك لا يمنع السكان من الشعور بالتفاؤل
والتلذذ بطعم الانتصار